we're less than 500 Days from election
day 2024. so let's take the Pulse of the
nation
between the president's CPAP marks you
saw him cocaine gate and the disastrous
rollout of bidenomics not to mention
Hunter
Democrats are spiraling right now and
why wouldn't they be worried
NBC news shows that 70 percent 7-0 of
Americans believe Biden should not run
for re-election that includes 51 percent
of Democrats a majority of his own party
his overall approval rating stands at
just 40.5 percent
to put that into context there's there
hasn't been a less popular president at
this point in over 40 years
as a result some Democrats find
themselves desperate for an alternative
enter Gavin Newsom now he's 55 years old
and he's become the latest Democrat
proxy to hit the campaign Trail for
Biden
and even though he denies any interest
in running in 2024 mm-hmm
some observers are beginning to question
his motivation
one California GOP consultant saying
quote he's putting in time and effort
that no one else outside the White House
appears to be doing
he's acting like the candidate in
Waiting someday it may actually pay off
for him
joining me now to discuss Doug Schoen
Democrat pollster and former adviser to
President Clinton Matt Tower he's a
chairman of Insider advantage and Tom
Bevin president and co-founder of real
clear politics three smart dudes on
politics to give us the pulse of the
nation so Doug what do you make of this
idea that Gavin Newsom is somehow the
Democrats Ace in the Hole for 2024. do
you think that's true or is this just
cable news fodder
no no no I think what Gavin Newsom is
doing he is positioning himself in case
Joe Biden does not that he is in a
position to step into the rights Kamala
Harris is the likely nominee if Biden
doesn't run but Newsome is trying to
blunt her Advantage by touring the
country aggressively he won't run
against Joe Biden very hard to beat an
incumbent president but he is
positioning himself on the eventuality
that the president ultimately for
whatever reason doesn't run for
re-election
yeah it's obvious I mean sometimes
things like that are just self-evident
uh Matt are you seeing in the polling at
all that the problems at the White House
and I know the cocaine stuff wouldn't be
resonating yet but overall with Hunter
and investigations and the smoke is that
having an impact even inside his party I
mean or his pull his numbers going down
even more recently
well you know it's funny I talked to the
bow tie upholster uh Robert kahali who
I'm I'm launching a podcast with in a
couple weeks we talked about this very
issue today we're actually not seeing
the penetration of these issues like you
would you would expect but part of that
is because which has been alluded to all
through out this evening and that is
that the a lot of the Legacy Media will
not cover the issues that are affecting
the bidens and that they do cover them
for example the cocaine issue they get
to it they drop it and they don't want
to really go back so we're not seeing
the numbers change that much but you
have to also understand thyness reached
a certain level which I wouldn't expect
him to dip substantially below until he
had some major incident of moving
further down
okay uh Tom let's let's assume for a
moment that Biden is the nominee uh he's
got another crisis potentially waiting
for him at The Ballot Box according to
recent polling nearly all 86 percent of
Hispanics say economic conditions are
only fair or they're poor three quarters
say the same thing about their personal
financial situation by two to one they
say Joe Biden's policies are hurting
their families so Tom how significant in
is this shift we saw a shift in 2020 the
Democrats have long relied on the
Hispanic vote in certain key States
does it cut even worse in their
Direction
well listen they have to be concerned
about the trend over the last few Cycles
uh because Donald Trump actually
increased his his vote share with
Hispanics Republicans did in in 2022 as
well and again you mentioned it's going
to come down to the same key States and
those include Nevada and Arizona were
about a third of the population is
Hispanic but also places like Florida
Georgia has a Hispanic population as
well so Hispanics are going to play a
pivotal role in the upcoming election
and Democrats need to make sure uh that
they maintain a sizable Advantage
because if they don't they're going to
have to make that up somewhere else
yeah where do you make it up it's
exactly right uh Doug there's another
Canary in the coal mine as we move along
and pick your brains here for the DNC
there's a Washington Post ABC poll that
recently asked voters who do you think
did a better job handling the economy
and amongst Hispanics the response was
overwhelming 55 prefer Donald Trump just
36 percent prefer biodynamics do you see
that Doug translating into changes in
voting trends
oh I think absolutely Pete this is a big
problem for the Democrats that uh is
clear and apparent in swing States and
indeed nationally and it puts Senate
seats at risk congressional seats and
the party is yet to address it my
concern is that the Democrats believe
Hispanics are only interested in
identity politics when they believe in
Traditional Values they are
anti-communist to a very large degree
and as you point out rightly they are
substantially impacted by an economy
where inflation is up wages are down the
cost of living is getting ever higher
yeah man I mean how do they address it
if economics is not the way you know a
lot of Hispanics are much more uh
culturally and socially conservative and
they don't want gender pronouns for
their Elementary School students uh I
mean this is how do they then try to win
back that constituency when their base
is going so hard in the other direction
I don't know if they can uh Doug nailed
it yes that that's an issue that they
have not been able to address and I also
to what Tom said earlier look at some of
these states like Florida look at Orange
County Osceola County which are counties
in Central Florida that normally go
heavily Democrat in races because of the
Puerto Rican population in those
counties this time desane has carried
one of those counties and he lost the
larger one the orange by only four
percentage points this is a trend you
see with Brian Kemp in Georgia the
Hispanic population continues to drift
even in these midterms in some of these
key States towards the Republican party
and I don't see any way right now the
Democrats are going to Stave that off at
least I've seen nothing that that
indicates that that's going to take
going to take place until they make some
major changes and some of those are
cultural and I don't think they're going
to want to make those cultural changes
in their presentation
Tom real quick back to where we started
I can't let you off the hook do you
think Biden will be the nominee in your
crystal ball with all you've seen
look I think you guys are stuck right
now they're stuck with him right now but
I agree I mean the fact that we're still
seeing these stories about Gavin Newsom
and other Democrats uh is because
Democrats they like Biden uh they
support him like his policies but they
want to give him a gold watch and see
him off the stage they have concerns
about his his stamina his age his mental
acuity and they'd prefer to go with
someone younger they're just stuck with
him right now
yeah they'd like to say Joe just go over
there but they can't all right Doug Matt
and Tom thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else